sobre la decisión de Estados Unidos de
suministrar municiones de racimo a
Ucrania el país sigue contaminado por
dichos artefactos utilizados por Estados
Unidos durante la guerra de Vietnam y el
Primer Ministro unseng instó a
Washington a no olvidar su pasado
sería el mayor peligro para los
ucranianos durante muchos años o hasta
100 años si se utilizan bombas de racimo
en las zonas ocupadas por Rusia en el
territorio de Ucrania las controvertidas
bombas tienen un legado mortal las que
quedan sin explotar pueden matar y
mutilar a civiles prohibidas por más de
120 países las municiones de racimo se
han utilizado en conflictos en todo el
mundo laos Irak Sudán chechenia entre
otros Reino Unido España y Alemania se
han manifestado en contra de la decisión
aunque reiteran su apoyo Ucrania pero
los aliados expresan su desaprobación
solo en palabras
creo que la posición alemana sigue
siendo correcta al pronunciarse en
contra de las municiones de racimo pero
no puede apuñalar a Estados Unidos por
la espalda en la situación actual
Washington defiende la medida
argumentando que Rusia ya ha usado las
bombas y afirma que Ucrania está
consumiendo las municiones más rápido de
lo que Estados Unidos y Europa pueden
producirlas se trata de mantener a
Ucrania en la lucha usted acaba de estar
allí habló con el presidente sobre la
contraofensiva y en cierto modo no va
tan rápido como a él le gustaría el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
admitió que era una decisión difícil
Aunque no es popular Ucrania también
defiende que las bombas de racimo son
necesarias para ganar la guerra